it was a social media saga that gripped
us all
fellow wags and former friends embroiled
in a bitter round when colleen rooney
wife of wayne rooney
accused rebecca vardy wife of jamie
vardy
of leaking stories to the sun in a
public post last october she said she'd
spent a long time
trying to figure out who it could be and
for some reason
she had a suspicion then came the
dramatic accusation rebecca vardy's
account she claimed
was behind the leagues and stories like
this one
appearing in the papers she posted it to
two million followers she posted it on
instagram and twitter
twitter she has 1.2 million followers
instagram around 800 000.
so of course it just went nuclear
and and and it snowballed and snowballed
and snowballed and it gets
these things get picked up very quickly
by websites and then it just became this
absolutely massive story
that here we are still more than a year
later talking about
at the time it was dubbed a wag war a
wagothic christie mystery
but today documents given to court
showed the extent of the abuse rebecca
vardy had faced online since
one message sent to her on instagram
read you fat
ugly rat i hope you and your baby rot
and die
an extremely painful death another said
your baby deserves to be put in an
incinerator
the hearing today was all about how
colleen rooney's tweet could have been
interpreted
rebecca vardy's lawyers argued the post
didn't use the language of suspicion
but that of truth the court heard how
four people including rebecca vardy had
access to her instagram account her
husband jamie vardy his social
media manager and her agent and colleen
rooney's lawyers say that she never said
rebecca vardy was unequivocally
responsible
instead she said it was rebecca vardy's
account
a hundred miles away rebecca vardy was
pictured getting ready for dancing on
ice in nottingham today
she's always denied leaking stories to
the sun
tomorrow a judge will decide what both
sides have to prove
if this goes to trial ali fortescue sky
news